in a tweet he said to the leaders of
Iran do not kill your protesters
thousands have already been killed or
imprisoned by you and the world is
watching more importantly the USA is
watching turn your internet back on and
that reporters roam free stop the
killing of your great Iranian people my
kana is joining us from Washington DC so
this was one of the latest tweets but
there's been a series of tweets not only
in English but in Farsi as well what are
we to read into all of this indeed yes
well president Trump started tweeting
late last night calling on expressing
his support for demonstrators in Iran
also as you mentioned tweeting some of
them in Farsi this is symptomatic of
what appears to be an administration
position to bring pressure maximum
pressure to bear on Iran in the forms of
external pressure such as sanctions both
economic and individual while at the
same time seeking internal division
internal resistance so in the view of
the Trump administration the Iran
government facing pressure both from
without and within the tenor of all the
Trump administration it smokes people's
statements in the course of today has
been precisely this that Iran is facing
pressure from within and without and
finding it very difficult to withstand
such pressure and we understand the
defense secretary has been speaking to
this Sunday talk shows what has he been
saying well Marcus burr appeared on a
number of the shows basically backing
the administration's position that there
was an imminent threat that led to the
assassination of a senior Iranian
general a few days ago arguing to that
this was absolutely necessary to carry
out but at the same time not giving any
real details about what the imminent
threat was this is replying to questions
in Congress to be more specific about
what the threat is the Secretary of
Defense also said that he couldn't
specifically say that for embassies had
been threatened and were part of an
imminent threat this is something that
has been said by President Trump
nonetheless the Secretary of Defense
says
there was the imminent threat and
embassies would have been the likely
target but despite all of this he
insists that President Trump is still
open to negotiation well it is still the
legitimate government if you will of
Iran and what we've said I've said
publicly the president certainly has
said is we will meet with them we're
willing to sit down and discuss without
precondition a new way forward a series
of steps by which Iran becomes a more
normal country one must mention that the
Iranian government has made absolutely
clear that there can be no negotiation
no discussion of any kind until the u.s.
lifts the sanctions that it's imposed in
recent months the u.s. far from lifting
these sanctions showing every sign of
wanting to intensify them okay my kind
of thank you